yes lisa how are you we've dylan's this
is an american irish restaurant with an
indian
nurse connected to it
it's hard for me to believe that dylan's
has lasted this long okay and you had
eight people leave on you yes we kind of
lurch between catastrophe and disaster
my wife my family we started this
restaurant to make a new life but uh the
restaurant is not doing that well
dylan's good evening how can i help you
i hired martin to take care of this
business
i had an objective the idea was to
capture the best of all who are we
choosing from we have beef buna which
menu lamb chops shepherd's pies it's the
waves of the future hamburgers indian
diners will be everywhere
i think people are a bit confused as to
like what kind of restaurant this is
i don't know what each manager does
specifically
i'm the general manager i'm the
operations manager and i'm a floor
manager here
nobody really knew khan was a manager he
doesn't do anything yet i don't like to
work here because everything's so messed
up
i think in an ideal world martin would
be an ongoing character in a reality tv
series
responsibilities include an awful lot of
things i make sure that everything runs
something's broken i fix it
i make sure that there's toilet paper to
wipe your butt with
frequently i will have to cook something
because the cooks who make the indian
food
don't know how to make american food
if we get customers in here i will walk
up to tables serve them their food and
they'll be slotting flies away okay it
is disgusting
the kitchen is not clean
that problem has been eradicated now i
think it has
where's the fly
for last six months we are losing like
20 to 30 000 a month i cannot continue
losing money like this i don't want to
continue with this nightmare i will do
anything and everything
what garden ramsay asked me to do to
make this place as successful
[Music]
ironically gordon's successful new york
restaurant is only two blocks away from
this kitchen nightmare
dylan's with the canopy all taped out
and
what the [ __ ] is that sign there it's
like a scoreboard
[Music]
money hello
gordon ramsay
martin general manager this is dylan
indian restaurant indian restaurant yes
it doesn't sound like an indian does it
no no dylan's no when i first met gordon
i seem to be a fairly intimidating guy
and that's exactly what he was mohammed
islam the owner of the place muhammad
how are you fine thank you
hello
jenna jenna nice to see gordon
definitely has a presence about him i
don't know whether or not i should be
terrified or just relax and go with
everything this is andrew operation
manager general manager operation
manager yes one rocky table trust you to
pick the worst table in the house let's
sit this table shall we yeah
okay good
flies everywhere
uh martin yes um we're such a huge menu
am i writing thing there's two kitchens
there's two different chefs in one
kitchen they work alongside each other
british italian buffalo yes the only
thing that's not on here is chinese
you know me this busy for lunch oh
actually it's a little busy today
we don't have people coming in because
they see an empty restaurant sometimes i
don't get a table at all
from the main menu assorted vegetarian
appetizers and then for main course the
lamb biryani and beef booner from the
american menu i'll go for the
salmonismos please thank you you're
welcome
god i'm lonely
i need the appetizers first are you okay
i'm quite excited to see the reaction
got like great service great food so
it's a win-win situation the walls are
ghastly
looks like it's been plastered with
hospital linen that's where the
customers go after they come out this
restaurant
of course there's no [ __ ] salmon why
would there be [ __ ] salmon when
gordon ramsay ordered his lunch
he must have looked into a [ __ ]
crystal ball because he ordered
something
that we didn't have let me just make
sure that i can order something that
they don't have
[Music]
there's two fritters those ones both are
vegetable they're both vegetables yes
may the lord above
not poison me oh man
in terms of beauty there's not exactly
an indian classic is it it looks like a
dehydrated turd
[Music]
there's meat in there
um that one's got meat in there it's not
vegetarian it tastes like lamb
if he were a vegetarian i would expect a
lawsuit it's gonna be fun to ask them
about
you guys are
killing me right now the assorted
vegetarian appetizer plate has to be
vegetarian
he just had a meat one
lock on wood the worst is over all right
okay
beef booner
and plant biryani
and she's bringing a plate for you
thanks darling
would you uh would you mind getting me a
clean one
[Music]
so
what the [ __ ] is that always worries me
when i stick tomato roses
on top of food and when the tomatoes
rotten
[Music]
that is not a piece of beef
does that look like a piece of beef to
you
it's dry it looks like pork if that's
beef then hey
i was born in bangladesh
gomez he says to try this it's pork
pretty sure it's pork is it beef
yeah
it is
no
yeah it was lamb
so now it was lamb gordon didn't seem to
enjoy much of anything and that's how it
usually goes with customers where did
you start on this one
potatoes are sick martin they look like
they were cooked at least a week ago oh
that's good
and frozen salmon too
andrew that's good
you have come to the rescue once again
one of the greatest chefs in the world
wants something to eat and i had to make
it
thank you
so this is from the american kitchen
it looks like a doormat
another fly
huh
is this normal
um
yes it is who made this um i did so
you're the operations manager you're yes
the chef as well yes we haven't got any
other chefs in the bag that can cook
this food they don't know how to cook
any western style food we do me a favor
yes
not with pleasure pretty much everything
that could go wrong went horribly and
catastrophically wrong oh my god
callus juice yeah pleased to meet you
gordon tell him in a really nice way
yeah your food is [ __ ]
last time you put a shaped person
together food was land
old-fashioned i've eaten it i don't feel
too good
but it says that that lamb is probably
the old lamb and serve me old lamb
i embarrassed to see
the situation
with yourself
they get a little nervous that they made
a mistake in there made a mistake
maybe they stand that cotton has a very
high compared to mine i didn't expect
it's gonna go that bad
[Music]
after gordon's lunchtime fiasco he now
tries to understand how this restaurant
is managed
no i'm not worthy of sparkling water i
have to have tap water here
right here are we going to reset this
table eeny meeny miny moe catch your
manager by the toe you are what
you're the floor manager manager
holy mackerel when i came to work i was
nervous but at the same time i was happy
because i have a chance to work with
chef ramsey
that's why you're here
so you can fix the place
you think it's that funny and easy to do
everybody here hates khan and i can't
fire the guy because he's protected by
muhammad now we have a floor manager
operations manager and general manager
i was resting just thinking of various
things i've got to sort out one of the
waitresses was rubbing my hair
it was a natural thing
how many managers this place need i
found a new manager we now have a floor
manager and amongst the operations
manager that's managed by the general
manager three [ __ ] managers and
they're all [ __ ]
with a better understanding of the staff
structure it's time for gordon to see
the staff in action at a dinner service
welcome nice to you
are you used to looking over the menu we
were just sort of debating whether we
wanted something on the american side
the bar on the indian side the indian is
very good where are we choosing from
which menu it's also becoming clear to
gordon that the multiple styles of menu
is not a positive but a negative well
i'm just going to go with my gut
[Music]
okay ready
okay farooq
oh [ __ ] holy moses
oh dude
[ __ ] me
[Music]
lift it off the floor and don't put it
on the floor hello madam floor manager
operations manager general manager
anybody
mamid
can you explain to gomez yes yeah that
we've got to stop putting things on the
floor
it's unhygienic
and it could be dangerous too it's very
dangerous yes
it's 40 minutes into the service and
unbelievably no food has left the
kitchen my first table still hasn't
gotten their andre
[Music]
one of the major reasons for the delay
chaos in this restaurant
this is the kitchen
they already done it no
i only give him the salad who's in
charge here i'm taking over expediting
here you're expediting yes mohammed what
are you doing in here i'm trying to help
them up you've got three managers two
chefs eight girls out the front and no
one can [ __ ] delegate oh my god
okay kids one order of salmon left one
salmon special let everybody know and
when information is shouted from the
kitchen martin is busy again not with
customers but with his phone oh my god
okay that has to be ready before this
goes up
ultimately martin doesn't belong in a
leadership position on the floor to do
something about it this place is running
in chaos it's totally dysfunctional and
there needs to be leadership here so
what are you cooking tonight
[Music]
nothing nothing at all
get me the general manager martin please
all right
not your party
gordon ramsay was really getting under
my skin
okay right uh this young man's here he's
standing here and he hasn't anything to
cook is this how you run a place no i
don't want a place like this all right
why did it take me to let you know that
he's standing there playing with
radishes
because um
you're busy
that's a horrible thing to say but i was
busy at the front day yes
he was alluding to my relationship with
the waitresses yeah you get off on it
gale stroping your hair
massaging your [ __ ] ego
you're such a fake i'm not faking just
why why are you saying i'm a fake you've
got members of your team standing here
getting paid doing [ __ ] all i've never
met a general manager so [ __ ] as you
okay if this was your money would you
let him stand here playing with his dick
that's what you're doing here you're
riding mohammed you know you're skinning
that poor man yes you [ __ ] up you're
taking advantage of a weak rich man
that's what's just [ __ ] clicked in my
mind he got personal he was accusing me
of riding muhammad this type of thing
and that got me because how the hell
have you got the right to say something
to me they don't even know me we've got
more staff than customers tonight and we
still can't get a [ __ ] ride
general manager
general toss park
[Music]
what is going on back there this is
seriously the worst service i've ever
had in the city
an hour and a half into dinner service
and only a few dishes have made their
way to customers who are not exactly
thrilled with dylan's dining experience
and those who haven't received food are
getting ready to leave in two minutes
we're leaving and you know we asked like
seriously two minutes we're leaving what
else i can do for you right now so it
doesn't make you happy
you tell me
sorry ladies or i can discount your bill
[Music]
it's day two and gordon has already been
appalled by the food and dismayed by the
inadequate management
time to do the thing i've been dreading
most yeah getting into the kitchen i am
not looking forward to this part
[Music]
when will these change last um that do i
need
well at least the flies look fresh oh my
gosh
i have no idea why is the flies there is
a lot of flies here
[Music]
[Applause]
what is that i don't know what it is
you don't know
moldy
that is quite frankly the worst
hamburger i've ever seen in my entire
life
oh my god
these were my [ __ ] potatoes for lunch
you do me a favor yes either
thank god i sat the little [ __ ] down
to eat them that's not a potato
green chicken
what goes on down here
[Applause]
[Music]
what's that smell
[ __ ] god's sake
look at that
look
cockroaches
holy [ __ ] my god that is the worst
hamburger i've ever seen in my entire
life having discovered the terrible
conditions in the kitchen gordon now
ventures down to the basement of the
restaurant to check out what's lurking
below
what's that smell
what
what is that is that for rats or mice
food for the
so we have got rats here
that is all over the place
[Music]
there's rat droppings look at them all
everywhere
that's right
oh my good god
look at the cockroaches
oh my god look i've got one in my
[ __ ] hair it's cockroaches boxes full
of them
look
look at them all
oh my god look there they are there in
refrigeration
oh [ __ ] it
oh my god oh no
look at that
[Music]
oh my god look at them
there you go
there you go
i was shocked it's like a nightmare look
mammoth i mean it's it's not even a
pepper it's rotten i'm worried about the
flies in the dining room i know where
they're [ __ ] breeding now look at it
i've eaten here
come on
martin
uh we will miss you hopefully see you
soon take care bye
okay yeah i need martin urgently he's a
gentleman yes yeah good you're you're
needed right now i'm leaving right now
yes needed in the kitchen urgently
are you in charge of this are you
responsible for this
that is the salad i had lunch time to
open the bag and bang out comes the
flies
uh gentlemen it gets worse than that
it's green
it's beyond edible it's disgusting look
at the color of those chicken wings
everything in there was putrid how long
has that been in there
can you give me an answer because i'm
[ __ ] myself yes uh there's a head
chef responsible for this trying to
rectify it kill somebody
we're not passing the bug but i know my
general manager knows what the [ __ ]
going on in my fridges where are your
standards
look at it
let me just tell you something i've
eaten here
where's that from
that's been sliced
that's gone out what is that where is it
hey madam where's that tomato gone
look
it's [ __ ] rotten you [ __ ] idiot
it's rotten
has a customer just being served a slice
of tomato
so where is it oh my god
[Music]
things are looking pretty
look
glum
it's
rotten mohammed
tell him in your language he'll kill
somebody
[Music]
what do we need a death in the
restaurant before some [ __ ] gets a
grip
[Music]
how many tables are out there there's
three three you tell those three tables
this is the luckiest day of their
[ __ ] life okay
[Music]
the only thing worse than having tables
sent away is knowing that well i was
going to serve them could make them sick
no one is getting served on this [ __ ]
mission tonight let's make that clear
yes or no
anyone against that no no good
that didn't go down too well he was
extremely angry extremely pissed off we
are not
ever
again serving any of this food i don't
give a [ __ ] what anyone says can you go
and tell them that the kitchen is closed
right now out there and telling the
truth
tell them now gordon was so
outraged so
angry
i've never seen anything like it from
green burgers to [ __ ] furry cucumber
to [ __ ] ranted potatoes
i'm sorry to inform you that we are not
going to be serving dinner this evening
chef ramsay's shut down the kitchen
it's just disgraceful i feel
terrible that it's gotten to this point
i'm [ __ ] speechless
it's a nightmare
this is so horrible i should close down
this place this is worse than a
nightmare
[Music]
gordon has encountered one of the most
disgusting kitchens he has ever seen oh
my god
and so he must take serious action
let's go
[ __ ] us
[Music]
i want these guys to know i mean [ __ ]
business
a clean means a proper clean
right you dirty little [ __ ] where are
you
[Music]
i was just looking at him
and thinking
okay when i say clean i mean clean yeah
guys let's go
these guys are professional steam
cleaners yeah
guys kitchen straight through there
it wasn't just cleaners it was cleaners
plus they're dressed like people from
star wars for god's sake
and you guys are doing it with them yeah
oh god
[Music]
phase one of gordon's mission to seek
out and destroy all moldy rotten and
contaminated foods
we've got work to do the next phase of
operation sterilize steam clean every
square inch of the kitchen
[Music]
now it's time to enlighten muhammad and
his managers with a little trip a couple
of blocks away to the kitchen of
gordon's new york restaurant okay i want
to show you something
the difference between night and day
this
is a kitchen
[Music]
all kitchen should be like this
gordon's kitchen is absolutely
spectacular no matter what size
restaurant you are you can keep a clean
shop and you can keep it organized open
the fridge door martin
[Music]
we went to the london that was a walk of
shame twice a day these fridges are
cleaned
this
is heaven that was hell
[Music]
in order to reach out to the local
indian community and new yorkers at
large gordon has come up with his
strategy for the menu contemporary
indian cuisine does he know we're in
broadway
where are we new jersey no no new jersey
oh [ __ ] me well yeah he doesn't even
know we're in [ __ ] new york we are in
new york restaurant
right
with this salmon we're gonna make a bit
of a broth right coconut and tomatoes
and onions dried the secret behind the
scallop is nice and pink it's sweet a
little bit of curry powder yes yes and
then from there
just
sit on top of the chutney
pan see it scallops a warner
chutney wonderful crispy salmon with a
tomato coconut curry broth he just
opened my eyes to what can be done clean
modern
way to serve indian food very good
look at me oh jeez give a cuddle [ __ ] it
out okay very very good
tell him he's only a scallop yeah we
haven't lost our children okay okay you
can let go now
i can let go now
it can let [ __ ] go now i did okay
good
[Music]
to help execute gordon's menu makeover
he has enlisted the help of one of the
top indian chefs in new york city vikas
khanna good to see you buddy are you
welcome
i need you here to work with the team of
chefs and to get this place back on the
map
yeah it's beautiful location we're in
the heart of manhattan we can do it here
[Music]
later in the night gordon's design team
is brought in to dramatically transform
the restaurant's interior and exterior
it's a new day
the tacky electronic sign is being
removed and the restaurant is given an
authentic indian name purnima which
means full moon follow me let's go here
we go there we are all blindfolded much
to our chagrin i'll tell you okay
on the count of three
take off your blindfolds one
two
three
welcome
wow
haven't they done an amazing job great
job amazing job mohammed have a look for
him down here it's like now you're
filming wow
what a difference isn't it beautiful
beautiful it has a nice clean crisp look
it looks not like it's been done by
professionals the way it should oh
wow this is beautiful isn't it lovely
i'm happy to come into work now and not
see the material
it's so much more than i thought it'd be
new chairs
new bulkheads
new linen new pictures
and it looks like something that is
classy yes he just turned this
restaurant from zero to 100. we're gonna
go outside and have a quick look outside
[Music]
wow
[Music]
stand back a little bit there's no
confusion the color's beautiful yes
i'm not gonna miss that sign i'm so glad
to have it gone it looks like a real
restaurant again the amazing job
after working through the night vikas is
ready to present the new menu he
designed with gordon
the old menu has been replaced with
classic indian dishes that have a modern
twist everything is done very simple
according to american palette i didn't
know that indian food like that existed
kerala fisherman's curry okay that's a
very basic curry we move to the next
list we have karai shrimp here after the
trio we have the chicken kurma we are
using saffron real saffron for this
flavor mr vickers is so cute he is a
magician to me
and then garden's recipe of saffron
cauliflower the menu reflects these
values of freshness and food vibrant
flavors and it's very approachable for
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
with the kitchen menu and decor all in
good shape
it's time for gordon to turn his
attention back to the staff
big big big night yes this place is
about to be relaunched properly tonight
it has to work okay what's your role for
tonight general manager i'm in front of
house um i'll be meeting greetings will
you do me a favor when the customers sit
down will you not sort of be so false
when you jump on just sometimes i feel
it's so in your face it's intimidating
for them
okay yeah yeah watching your performance
i was like
tacky will you promise to keep your
phone off in the middle of
he promised to be service to staff needs
when necessary yeah will you attempt to
act as a general manager for the first
time ever stepping into this business
yeah i like like i always do yes take it
as your caffeine hangout area
that is a great morale booster before
the opening of this amazing new
restaurant
will you actually treat it as a business
if you could try to make some
improvement this evening
please
yeah martin he's not qualified for a gm
i don't see the confidence that he needs
martin's not full of [ __ ] okay
you're giving him such a hard time and
it's making me angry i'm frustrated for
the lack of respect this man has that's
with him not with you so would you mind
keeping your nose out of my business
don't try and interrupt me
stupid this is a loyal worker oh yeah no
i'm sorry you don't need your mignon to
try and convince me how good you are on
the back of what i've experienced is
that clear martin please
garden help us to achieve that one
amazing job yes let's group ourselves we
do the job right absolutely definitely
and then we see this garden we did it
thank you mohammed i've been waiting for
that for the last week i'm really
pleased that it came out so now i want
to see positivity from everybody
absolutely everybody and if there's
anyone who doesn't think they can pull
on the rope like that look for a new job
it's the morning of relaunch and gordon
has organized a plan to spread the word
in manhattan it's a purnima parade look
at that
[Music]
wow what a brilliant idea uh promoting
purnima restaurant off we go and we'll
jump on yes
it's amazing
the girls
musics and the promoting ideas all of
them yeah i love it i love you i'm glad
you're happy now
[Music]
people are asking where the restaurant
is and it was nice to be able to do
something together we needed that more
than anything because i think all of our
spirits were so broken
it's so romantic all of a sudden you've
all come alive my god
it's only two hours to go until the
doors open and the restaurant is booking
up
the future of purnima rests greatly on
tonight's reopening i understand
absolutely
tonight is a golden opportunity but he
needs his staff to rise to the occasion
hello good evening
i will say this table right here i got a
table right here for you
it is very exciting to see these
restaurants full again
the kitchen is under the strong
leadership of vikas so he's gonna bring
the food but gordon will be keeping an
eye on the general manager martin
advertisers everybody take some time the
success of purnima depends on the
teamwork that's the crucial point of
running purnima
uh martin yep give me the phone
[Music]
is it on it's off it's off
it's off
okay
yes are you ready for order some samosas
and scallops and some chicken
one chicken tikka tree
this is the new start for purnima new
deck all new menu contemporary fresh and
how exciting it's all fresh all new and
wonderful
everything's just going perfectly well
but
[ __ ]
martin's still here
[Music]
excellent nice atmosphere in the dining
room nice atmosphere
customers are responding well to the new
menu and the first wave of orders is now
hitting the kitchen
i need one lamb chop medium bread please
piping hot please
take this take this
[Music]
we got to turn some customers tonight
we've got to turn tables yeah
it's good it's really great cauliflower
is great
but as the orders start to pile in
martin's lack of managerial skills start
to show
so that they want the lamb
the ladies that yeah
and the wait staff becomes confused
can somebody take this place which is
causing disorder in the kitchen and
everything is starting to back up martin
khan the food's sitting here no one's
moving their ass yes it's getting cold
and cold and cold
[Music]
oh my god how'd that happen i need
another race please
service get me martin please yeah
quickly yeah
[Music]
excellent everyone's standing in it
donna can you get out the rice please
[Music]
martin could you sweet the rice then
we'll rather everyone's selling it yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah be nice to do
something yeah so we don't have to send
more food to the rats that's great
finally found a job oh [ __ ]
even on a night with a top chef at the
helm
martin's mismanagement of his waiters
has caused problems in the kitchen
and the customers are paying the price
okay
we're now just starting to turn these
first tables but panic sets in customers
are complaining about food being cold
and these staff are not used to being
busy especially like this
[Music]
it's cold because it's [ __ ] lying
around just take this please service
please
i never served as many customers before
who's running the restaurant martin
yeah somebody ordered this 33
i'm not gonna say anything negative
about the restaurant but i don't
understand this restaurant
let's go on there you go rather than a
big trade right where you going what
table
what what's that for bacchus
vacuous v cass i don't think that that
martin understands what a general
manager really should be doing don't
make any phone calls along the way
straight to the table
why is that rice going cold now why
doesn't that be served no it's just
burning yes
it's actually burning i want the
customer to experience it hot not your
hand customers are complaining about the
food cold my man
you put the meal out just now i believe
corn is trying to get me
angry tired annoyed or whatever and
i wasn't taking any part with that
gordon has seen enough of martin's
managerial incompetence and believes he
may have found a solution
be honest with me
can you manage this place yes i can so
stop blending in and stand on your feet
okay yes i can do that i will try my
best to convince chef ramsay that i can
run this restaurant
ready ready everything is ready
that's okay that's okay relax with khan
taking the reins food is finally making
it out to the customers good man thank
you excellent pour the water use the
tray take it to the down there each and
every time table 44 need there or check
perfect all the best forever
this is great
with khan in the dining room and vegas
in the kitchen the restaurant is
beginning to run smoothly it was a very
very good experience for me and my whole
team and then make me feel good one two
three
tonight
i made over a hundred dollars i was so
happy make sure you guys come back again
all right
take care
[Music]
the grand opening of purnima was bumpy
in the middle but finished on a high
note um
however gordon knows his work is not
done
this place can be
phenomenal the location's extraordinary
this is a new start
you have to treat it as a new beginning
of course i mean in a perfect world i
would sacrifice one of your managers to
employ vegas
you cannot carry driftwood in your
business
out of the three managers
one has to go
[Music]
between you and i
martin has an amazing way of
manipulating you
and he's not worth his weight in terms
of what he brings to the table hearing
gordon ramsay say that to muhammad and
that makes me upset and angry the
frustration just boiled over
tonight tonight mohammed yeah i've never
used you i've i've respected you i'm
proud of what we've done i've never
cheated you might think
[Music]
so
this person i've respected and you've
had the audacity to accuse me of like
taking his mind off his back riding off
his back is is what you've said well
that is disgusting you have no right you
don't know that whatever whatever what
about you i have nothing to be guilty of
you what nothing you sat in it it's
rotten
yeah you ran it you sat in there yes you
wasted it yes i wasted it you encouraged
it
this wasn't always like this we it is
[Music]
you what nothing you sat in it yeah you
ran it you sat in there yes you wasted
it yes i wasted it you encouraged it
this wasn't always like this
it spiraled out of control and i asked
you to come on board i'm glad not guilty
i'm not guilty i'm not gonna take this
put down anymore nothing to be guilty of
listen this is my last night
and you said it was last night i'm
confused yes this is staying tonight
this is my last tonight okay please tell
the owner not me this is my last night
i'm out here i quit
[Music]
when martin left actually i'm very
shocked i didn't expect it's gonna go
that bad
think gordon ramsay is full of peace and
i'm extremely angry extremely pissed off
and i now turn my back and walk away
[Music]
with the success of the relaunch and the
change of management cornima has beaten
the odds and is now looking to a bright
future
in the following days purnima's
contemporary indian food and atmosphere
continued to generate great buzz
throughout new york city
[Music]
the restaurant's revenue increased and
naturally so did the service tips thank
you thank you so much and chef vikas
accepted an offer from muhammad to be
the restaurant's ongoing consultant
at any limit at any extent
thanks a lot appreciate it thank you
thank you
let's be honest it's gone exceptionally
well yes yes yes
great food great decor great bars happy
customers i really mean it thank you
bloody good job
i'm very happy with the changes gordon
has made here
he has given this place an opportunity
to thrive
and be a real restaurant for all of us
over here i thank you very very much
listen you're very welcome you've got
all the tools now do it don't stop
working hard gordon did what i thought
was completely impossible with the
restaurant
i can't my experience with shape garden
was wonderful i get that confidence that
we can run this business we can run this
place right successfully okay
okay
okay
[Applause]
excellent
good to see you guys
neighbours yes next time i'm coming to
eat i'm not coming to work yes okay yes
i like to
thank chef ramsay to being a part of
this great success before i thought he's
crazy but he said no he's a very
passionate man i like that very much
thank you
[Applause]
oh
what a transformation
i honestly didn't think we could turn
this around to this extent from what i
saw my first day here my god